it's time now for CVS deals this morning
we have a few things that just might
make your day a little easier with items
that could offer a little Comfort during
this stressful time of year all at
exclusive low prices
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Ashley Bellman joins us
with more good morning good morning
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Eve it's
the most wonderful time of year but
obviously the most stressful as you
mentioned so everything here is going to
make you feel a little more less
stressed at these starting with this the
calming heat neck wrap so you know what
you look like you could be a little bit
stressed I'm going to put this on your
neck a little bit of vibration heat you
can adjust that this is only 23.99 This
is 40 off today have this on anytime I'm
always cold this time of year whenever
I'm on my computer or on my phone I like
to just have this on to give me that
warmth to give me that little extra
Comfort it is something that you could
use every single day you are you falling
asleep I feel like you are so relaxed
right now
there you go so this is great 40 off
today I feel like every single person
that I know who was a little have you
been wrapping gifts have you been on
your phone this is something that you
could benefit from for sure cool all
right next okay so this for me in a
world of triple demix knowing that I'm
breathing in fresh air is going to make
me feel less stressed so this is the
clean light air purifier weighs less
than a pound you could stick this in
your cup holder in your car you could
take this on an airplane I had this
going on my ride on the way in because
you just never know I love the fact that
I could bring it from room to room with
me it uses UVA and HEPA filters to make
sure that the air around you up to 161
square feet is going to be purified and
it doesn't smell like anything unless
you use the essential oils in the sponge
in there and make it smell like whatever
you want interesting because you can
make it yes and it's only
99.99 today and it kills 99.9 of the
germs in the air there okay next is a
this is a blanket with a Twist so
GGY before it has been on t
ontian of these have been sold it's the
wearable blanket it fits most it is so
comfy cozy it's the one thing that you
could just throw on get on your couch
and just feel like cocooned and happy
also if you unfortunately have to go sit
outside and watch sporting events you
could bring this with you and then come
home throw it in the wash and it is good
to go comes in three colors and it is
only 24.99 today which is buy one get
one really great deal okay Ashley thank
you very much thank you happy Christmas
Eve happy Christmas happy first we
partnered with all these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head over to cbsdeals.com